what are you most afraid of
i guess i'll done live life
uh
i'm a i'm always a big fan growing up of
like
wild guys you know like these teddy
roosevelts who would go out and hunt
lions and
uh
like bar fighting guys i was obsessed
with the hunter s thompson types
and look
this is what i love about uh guys like
who's a good example
like hemingway hemingway was the
manliest guy he had the rifle and the
elephant gun and the whiskey and the
writing and the women and the fistfights
but
people forget it the other side of that
coin is i'm sure he was in a lot of
hotel rooms weeping i'm sure he was
lonely as [ __ ] i'm sure he had some
wicked hangovers i mean he killed
himself for christ's sake so obviously
he was dealing with something
so the key to me is having this
adventurous life living to the fullest
doing crazy [ __ ] scaring yourself but
also not killing yourself like also not
hating because i used to party a lot
hard i used to
bang a lot of gals and this is the flip
side is like this girl hates you now or
you got herpes or you're hungover or
your mom is like where where are you you
never call me anymore you're like oh my
mom i
let let ties go with my mom i gotta
connect so this horrible there's a
horrible side of the party animal the
keith richards we don't see
is not pretty
i mean he's already weird-looking
but
he's partying he's smoking he's living
but there's another side of that coin
and i think the key to life is living
that [ __ ] crazy awesome badass life
and also
having
some you know meaning and and a little
bit of uh what's the word
not just not killing yourself not going
sad not being depressed right there's a
medium there a sweet spot
does that make sense yeah yeah so taking
big
leaps and uh
hemingway grabbing life by the balls but
at the same time not crushing the balls
then yeah metaphor work it off perfect
like evil knievel we all know him what a
badass fearless oh man what a cool dude
he's got balls of steel but he also
lived like the back half of his life in
a [ __ ] uh you know barca lounger
where his legs were made of steel and he
couldn't see straight and his dick
didn't work so
you know what i mean you got to have a
balance but you still want the balance
i'm willing to take a little bit of [ __ ]
for
a little bit of fun
but you don't want to go too hard
because you got to still risk it i mean
hunter s thompson
it didn't end well
yeah that's quite a ride quite a ride
you